you
[Music]
there's a crime detectives follow the
clues they get close but then they reach
the water so they call in the underwater
criminal and investigator that's Mike
Barry hold on this is Mike Barry I dive
in very strange places looking for very
strange things
mike has been an underwater criminal
investigator for 35 years how easy is it
to get rid of a murder weapon all it is
is a flick of the wrist and someone's
mind that murder weapon is forever gone
they have no idea there are people like
me crazy enough to go down here search
law enforcement depends on guys like
Mike to preserve and recover evidence
your three cores in underwater Criminal
Investigation is body recovery vehicle
recovery and evidence recovery I get
called about twice a week sometimes more
sometimes less and when a call comes in
chances are Mike's in for a challenge
some of these locations are absolutely
disgusting our typical dive site is dark
it's deep it's cold it's full of
obstructions it's been Tama nated the
danger is there when you get in the
water you know I've had murders tell me
you know you'll never find it
I said well we'll see there's nothing
like finding the target when your hand
hits it and you feel it and you realize
you've got it for a public safety diver
there's no greater thing and when he's
out there searching for a body I look at
it as an honor because you realize the
importance of what you're asked to do
there's a family and there's no closure
until you bring them up you know not
every diver can do this not everybody
has it in their DNA
it's what I was meant to do I couldn't
think of anything better to do with my
life truth is I can't wait for the next
call to help someone in some way either
to bring closure or to bring a
conviction embalming students have to
understand the importance that every
face is different Morgan Freeman square
face Abraham Lincoln oblong face Kanye
West oval face my name is James Edward
Smith jr. I'm an instructor and clinical
director at Dallas Institute a funeral
service and I currently instruct
restorative art
[Music]
restorative art class provides a skill
set to be able to take a deceased person
who's experienced trauma to the head
and/or face and restore those features
in that face so that the family may have
an option for an open casket viewing or
visitation in a fifth quarter the
students are tasked with reproducing a
sculpture of a person that they choose
and the anatomy has to be accurate
students generally picked celebrities
you know they're popular faces and
students tend to want to try and
recreate those from our restorative art
project I did Jennifer Aniston Jack
White
Viola Davis Frieda Calif i decided to do
David Lynch taking on the assignment
requires each of the students to
understand the proportions for the
features of the face here in school
because it translates to what may happen
in the actual preparation room
it is an acquired skill the more you
practice the more proficient the better
you're going to become the expectation
of the family is that this is something
we can sometimes do right away but we
have to take into account the amount of
krama that the face has sustained we
need to have as much care when handling
the deceased as if they were in the
hospital under the care of a doctor
[Music]
I am very passionate about restorative
art because I believe it's important for
people to have the best memory picture
possible when it's time to say goodbye
we're task Azzam bombers to help
families have the option no matter the
cause of death to say goodbye to mom or
dad or brother or sister
[Music]
welcome to the National Fish and
Wildlife forensics laboratory in Ashland
Oregon our laboratory works very much
like a Police Crime Lab in that we
identify evidence and we try to link
suspect victim and crime scene together
for that evidence the big difference is
that our victim is a nonhuman
I'm Ken Goddard and the director of this
laboratory when our agency's evidence at
a border a custom Center wherever that
evidence will be packaged and shipped to
us our job is to analyze evidence
collected for wildlife or law
enforcement investigations our
laboratory primarily supports wildlife
laws in general specifically the
Endangered Species Act sadly were the
only full-service crime lab for wildlife
in the world we'd like not to be but
that's our reality the illness and
wildlife trade is huge it's probably in
the neighborhood of 17 18 19 billion
dollars a year we're certainly impacting
the trade but it's a desperately
difficult job here are some of the
scientists that help us solve crimes
against animals our veterinary
pathologist is dr. Becky Kagan my job is
to autopsy all of the animals that come
in here and try to figure out why they
died today I have two birds they're both
bald eagles they're wild animals they're
found dead my job is to figure out was
there a crime involved we can do CT
scanning here at the lab we take
photographs we do alternate light source
exam to help us solve the puzzle of why
this animal died one aspect of our work
that's typical of a crime lab is we
compare a known against an unknown for
us to identify let's say a feather or
maybe to identify the bones we would
compare that against tissue from a known
animal or to a skeleton and the fellow
responsible for our huge collection is
Johnny French our collection is 35,000
specimens give or take everything that
we have here has either been donated or
was seized in customs the uniqueness of
our collection helps us kind of keep
abreast of what we see in the wildlife
trade most of the time we have to remove
meat from bone in order to examine
specimens or to get them into our
reference collection easiest way to do
that is take the carcass and chuck it in
the flesh-eating beetles ink after the
beetles have finished with the carcass
that we threw in there we'll wash them a
couple of times and in
the bones are ready for the collection
heading up our genetics section is dr.
Mary Curtis the genetics team is
important to the functioning of the lab
because we look at items that other
parts of the lab can't identify items
that might be crafted to the point and
where you can't tell what their origin
is so we have access to over 40,000
individual tissue samples in our
reference collection that we use to
identify different species one of the
more interesting people in our lab is
dr. pepper trail our ornithologist I'm
an ornithologist a bird expert so I look
at bird evidence and use reference
specimens to compare to evidence items
to confirm the identification the kinds
of evidence that we receive is
incredibly varied we receive everything
from complete dead carcasses in good
condition to just bags of bones I've
identified over 750 species in the
course of my work here which would be a
pretty good life list for a lot of
birders the magnitude of the
international wildlife trade is
staggering every day into our laboratory
comes remains of dead animals from
around the world and someone needs to
provide the information needed to bring
wildlife criminals to justice it's
sometimes a sad job but it's a very
important job and
I believe that the world called cases is
wrong because it could be perhaps
something that's in a drawer somewhere
in an office but their family's hasn't
forgotten them and they're still looking
for them
and I just want to do my best to help
when authorities have failed to identify
the remains of a body there is very
little hope of closure for these john
and jane doe's but every year an
enterprising studio of student artists
used their knowledge of the human form
to try and breathe life into these cold
cases here we're doing a forensic
reconstruction of a real case trying to
get it as close as he used to look like
when he was alive so we can identify him
[Music]
we are given a 3d print not the real
skull we use it as a framework so we can
reconstruct the anatomy of the
individual first we start adding the
muscles on the framework given by the
bone and then we try to complete those
things that are not so clear like the
ear or the mouth
right now I'm working on Caucasian white
man between 40 to 60 years old there are
indications that he lost his teeth when
he was alive and his bones are telling
me all that these lifelike models are
provided to authorities often
reinvigorating investigations and
bringing much-needed closure to loved
ones after my first experience last year
I was lucky enough that the person was
identified and I got this beautiful
letter from the family members saying
thank you when we see this process it
feels almost like your resuscitating
someone but I know that beyond that
where your resuscitating is the life of
those families that are looking for this
person
[Music]